>> So we can actually work out what the VC
dimension of a finite H is and, in fact, it's easier
to just think about it in terms of an upper
bound. So, let's, let's imagine that the VC dimension of H
is some number, D. And the thing to realize from
that, is that, that implies that there has to be at
least two to the d distinct concepts. Why is that? Is
because each of the two to the d different labelings is
going to be captured by a distinct hypothesis in the class, because
if we can't use the same hypothesis to get two different labelings. So
that means that the, that two to the d is going to be less
than or equal to the number of hypotheses. It could be that there's
more, but there can't be any fewer, otherwise we wouldn't be able
to get things shattered. So, just you know, simple manipulation here, gives us
that d is less than or equal to the log base 2 of
h, so there is this logarithmic relationship, between the size of a finite
hyptothesis class. And the VC dimension of it,
and again, that's what we were seeing in
the other direction as well, that the, that the log of the hypo, size of the
hypothesis space was kind of playing the role
of the VC dimension in, in the bound.
Okay, that makes sense. And, and from that,
it's easy to see how 13 got in there.
>> Yes. It should be pretty much obvious
to even the most casual observer of 13.
>> Yes, I think that's right. So I don't
think there's any reason for us to explain it.
>> Yeah, I think one would have to really go back and look at the, at the
proof to get the details of why the, it has the form that it has, but, or at
least the details of the form. The, the, the,
overall structure of the form, I think we understand.
It's just that the details come out of the
proof and we're not going to go through the proof.
>> And I think that's probably best for everyone.
>> So what, what we're seeing at the moment is that
a finite hypothesis class or a finite VC dimension, give us finite
bounds, and therefore make things PAC-learnable. What's kind of amazing though
is that there's a general theorem that says, in general, if H is
PAC-learnable if and only if the VC dimension is finite. So
that means that, we know that anything that
has finite VC dimension is learnable from the previous
bound. But we're saying that it's actually the other
way as well, that if something is learnable it
has finite VC dimension. Or to say it another
way, if it has infinite VC dimension, you can't
learn it. VC dimension captures, in one quantity, the
notion of PAC-learnability, which is, which is really beautiful.
>> Yeah, I agree. That V and that C guy, they're pretty smart.